[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález continúa
avanzando la invasión de las tropas
rusas en el territorio ucraniano la
jornada de hoy tuvo varios hechos para
destacar la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas aprobó una resolución en
la que condena la invasión de rusia a
ucrania durante esta segunda sesión de
emergencia hubo acusaciones sobre el uso
de armas de guerra prohibidas y también
de ataques contra la población civil en
territorio ucraniano por su parte las
tropas rusas afirmaron ya haber tomado
el control de la ciudad de gerzón en el
sur de ucrania sería la primera capital
regional en ser conquistada por el
ejército ruso mientras tanto en hardcore
la segunda ciudad más poblada del país
siguen bajo asedio ruso así es como
están las cosas veamos la invasión de
ucrania está resultando más difícil de
lo que putin esperaba en el séptimo día
de guerra las fuerzas armadas de moscú
se encuentran con una fuerte resistencia
sobre el terreno entre los militares
rusos se han producido más bajas de lo
previsto y así como problemas logísticos
rusia enfrenta dificultades para hacer
llegar sus astros a todas sus tropas a
lo ancho del vasto territorio ucraniano
en un batallón ruso hay diez camiones
eso es todo eso proporciona autonomía
durante 48 horas después toda la unidad
tiene que detenerse hasta conseguir más
combustible y descansar la logística de
las fuerzas armadas rusas simplemente no
es suficiente para sostener operaciones
prolongadas en territorio hostil esta
podría ser la razón por la que el convoy
de 60 kilómetros de tanques rusos
todavía no ha entrado en kiev las
brigadas de blindados penetrando
lentamente en la capital eran un plan
vez después de que ucrania derribar a
los helicópteros rusos de combate que
tenían la misión de tomar por sorpresa a
la capital el día 1
la ofensiva rusa no avanza como estaba
previsto no se han alcanzado los
principales objetivos e incluso en la
doctrina rusa sabemos que si no se es
capaz de conseguir los objetivos clave
en las primeras horas añadir más tropas
invertir más días no va a hacer que la
operación sea un éxito win to make de
estos exacto a presión
en los últimos días rusia ha aumentado
sus ataques aéreos contra grandes
ciudades como contra heart con fe en el
este y odessa mariupol y gerson en el
sur lo que podría significar un cambio
de estrategia en chechenia y siria moscú
usó artillería y bombardeos para reducir
el terreno a cenizas
de hecho podría ser una maniobra
deliberada que de otras ciudades en
ucrania se están desgastando y la moral
irá bajando y en ese momento el convoy
ruso rodea que empieza el bombardeo de
la ciudad y luego el bombardeo con
artillería pesada no creo que tengamos
que asumir que rusia esté cerca de
retirarse de este conflicto
moscú renovó sus amenazas de escalada el
martes después de que putin ordenara
poner en alerta su arsenal nuclear
por otro lado el ministro de defensa de
ucrania dice tener pruebas de que el
ejército de belarús se prepara para
enviar tropas de apoyo a rusia una
información que el presidente alexander
lukashenko niega
del lado de eeuu han mantenido su apoyo
logístico a ucrania a través de los
aliados de la otan y a través de ayudas
económicas durante su primer discurso
del estado de la unión el presidente
estadounidense joe biden aseguró que
tropas de su país no pisarán suelo
ucraniano escuchemos
pero quiero ser claro nuestras fuerzas
no van a entrar en un conflicto con
fuerzas rusas en ucrania nuestras
fuerzas no van a ir a europa combatir en
ucrania sino defender nuestros aliados
se notan en el evento que putin decida
seguir moviéndose hacia el occidente
movilway mientras tanto desde la unión
europea pidieron cesar los ataques
contra la población civil y darle
espacio a la diplomacia por encima del
uso de las armas así lo dijo el
canciller alemán olaf scholz
y quiero pedir una vez más que se
detengan inmediatamente todas las
operaciones de combate deben cesar los
ataques a la población civil que las
infraestructuras civiles y por supuesto
debe haber de nuevo una gran oportunidad
para la diplomacia
de nuestra línea es clara no
intervendremos militarmente que eso se
aplica a la otan no lo hará y para todos
los demás en esta situación que eso
sería un error
desde ankara la embajada ucraniana en
turquía indicó que más de 2.000 civiles
han muerto desde el comienzo de la
invasión mientras que el cerco a la
ciudad de kiev la capital se estrecha
poco a poco de otra parte desde rusia en
una entrevista para la cadena al yazira
el ministro de relaciones exteriores de
rusia serguéi lávrov aseguró que el
presidente estadounidense joe biden sabe
que la única alternativa a las sanciones
impuestas a rusia es una tercera guerra
mundial que sería una guerra nuclear
devastadora de inmediato las alertas a
nivel mundial saltaron después de estas
declaraciones sin embargo horas después
la portavoz de la cancillería rusa maria
sharapova trató de bajar un poco la
atención y dijo textualmente abro
comillas mi país bajo ningún concepto
tiene la intención de apretar el botón
rojo nuclear
qué hay detrás entonces del discurso del
kremlin y del discurso del presidente
putin y cuál es el alcance de los hechos
más recientes en esta invasión de rusia
al territorio ucraniano para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a zaira vadillo
ella es analista internacional
historiadora con énfasis en historia
rusa y de la unión soviética estudia
también los procesos políticos en el
espacio postsoviético
está en la ciudad de londres en el reino
unido y también está con nosotros iván
widget él es analista internacional e
investigador de la universidad de tartu
estonia desde allí en el extremo
oriental de la unión europea se une a
esta conversación ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con todos sus comentarios
y preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook ya lo saben también en
instagram y en twitter como france24
bajo ese arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas comienzo
entonces con zaira en la ciudad de
londres
por el tema con el que habría yo la
presentación del programa y es esa
votación de una resolución de la
organización de naciones unidas una
decisión que no es vinculante pero
sorprenden algunas votaciones por
ejemplo la del salvador el salvador- se
abstuvo de tomar alguna posición y de
votar en esta en este voto en la
organización de naciones unidas que
interpretación se puede hacer de los
resultados y esa postura del salvador
bueno hay que entender que muchos países
en latinoamérica y también en el prof el
espacio soviético espacio postsoviético
mantiene un relación muy estrecha con
rusia en la área económica y no han
querido tomar una posición
ant agonizante con lo que está
sucediendo en ucrania hemos visto
también a extensiones de otros países
que fueran parte de la unión soviética y
que no han querido como tal tener una
confrontación con putin porque esto les
va a afectar económicamente no así que
yo veo más bien estas decisiones no de
tipo ideológico yo lo diría un poco
temático y estratégico no de mi parte
estratégico iván cuál es su percepción
sobre estas votaciones en la
organización de naciones unidas
al respecto de américa latina' estoy de
acuerdo con saber que en efecto hay un
interés económico hay una perspectiva
económica continuada una colaboración
con angustia más allá del conflicto y
encima de eso también hay una condición
geopolítica que los países de américa
latina quisieran encontrar aliados juega
del hemisferio con tal de fortalecer su
perspectiva al respecto de las grandes
potencias del continente por lo tanto
veo comprensible esta postura que toman
fuera de
megalatina de países como países en
áfrica y en asia y también varias
abstenciones y en varios casos eso tiene
que ver también con intereses
comerciales no obstante pienso que hay
bastante bastantes indicios que hay una
realidad que está que es el tema de la
agresión que viola varios los principios
fundamentales de relaciones
internacionales con respecto a la
soberanía y la integridad territorial
pero lo cierto es que la mayoría de los
países integrantes de la organización de
naciones unidas votaron de esta
resolución o una mayoría pero también
era importante analizar estos países que
se abstuvieron o que votaron en contra
iván continuó con usted allí en el
sureste de estonia para preguntarle por
uno de los temas que fue debatido en
esta reunión segunda reunión de
emergencia de las naciones unidas y es
el uso de armamento no permitido en
conflictos hay algunas denuncias que
supuestamente rusia las está utilizando
sobre todo en el asedio a la ciudad de
hardcore en el este de ucrania quienes
supervisan el uso del armamento a nivel
internacional quienes pueden dar
garantías que este armamento no permitió
está siendo usado por rusia y quien
podría exigirle al gobierno al kremlin
detener el uso de estas armas porque se
habla de bombas termo barricas las que
estaría usando rusia allí y de ser
confirmado que sanciones podrían pensar
sobre la federación
en este momento en términos prácticos la
única autoridad que pudiera detener
estos además que sting hidush es el
comando militar de uso
por el momento la información no sólo la
diplomacia entre ucrania y rusia y
occidente o si está detenida en gran
medida pero también otras otras
participaciones
con
organizaciones internacionales entre
ellas aquellas que monitorean el uso de
armamento distinguido de este modo hay
evidentes ya ha habido evidencia del uso
de semejantes además por parte de la
industria en otras batallas en otros
escenarios en otros conflictos
no ha habido una autoridad que haya sido
capaz de imponerse al camino de mandar
no respetarlas estas restricciones
según reportes rusia ya habría utilizado
algunas de estancias bombas termo
barricas durante el conflicto en
chechenia a finales de los 90 a
principios del 2000 hace ya un buen
tiempo tampoco hay una evidencia clara
sobre el uso de estas bombas es a ir a
esto a nivel internacional qué
consecuencias trae para un país como
rusia que es un país netamente militar
que la apuesta a que buena parte de su
industria sea enfocada en el desarrollo
de armamento nuclear y de armamento para
este tipo de combates no necesariamente
nuclear pero si armas de destrucción de
amplio rango como las bombas termo
barricas
bueno rusia realmente tiene un gran
mercado no un armamento militar vende a
muchos países de asia medio oriente y
también en latinoamérica su equipo
militar es parte de su
inteligencia militar no pero en relación
a estas bombas que
que también en el caso de siria se ha
podido documentar luego de finalidad
finalizada el conflicto las tensiones
grupos humanitarios han podido recopilar
información en relación al tipo de bomba
que se lanzó yo creo que ya rusia está
ahogado en muchas sanciones todavía
queda con otras sanciones que podrían
afectar su economía como sabemos en la
parte del gas y el petróleo que no han
sido sancionados pero yo creo que más
allá de un golpe moral no no creo que
vayan a haber otras sanciones en
relación al uso de este tipo de
armamento militar que no está permitido
en la guerra ya sabemos que en siria ha
habido casos en los que se ha probado
que había utilizado entretenía como muy
bien un segmento ha sucedido lo mismo
pero en fin estas partes de la guerra
también en muchas ocasiones acusado
alguno de los eeuu en el tipo de
armamento que utilizó en la guerra de
afganistán así que yo más más que pensar
que sanciones es una cuestión ética y
moral que el pueblo ruso y sus
dirigentes tienen que enfrentar digamos
de forma histórica porque bien que lo
que sucedió en chechenia se queda el
pasado pero yo creo que hay una huella
muy oscura en la historia de rusia y la
forma en que ese conflicto se llevó a
cabo yo yo no vería de esa forma no creo
que vaya a ver ya de percusiones quiero
que pasemos a hablar de el tema de la
población civil que son los ciudadanos
ucranianos los que han quedado en el
fuego cruzado sobre todo los que están
en la región del donbass que quedaron
entre los separatistas el ejército ruso
y el ejército ucraniano disputándose
está esta región del este de ucrania
pero ahora vemos también grandes
ciudades como por ejemplo mariupol
puerto importante en el mar de azov y
sobre todo heart cop que es la ciudad la
segunda ciudad más poblada y ucrania
llama mucho la atención que rusia esté
atacando asediando esta ciudad donde la
mayoría de la población es rusoparlante
que supuestamente lo que el ejército
ruso fue a defender en ucrania ese
supuesto genocidio y ese supuesto ataque
contra la población rusa en el este de
ucrania pero las imágenes que llegan
desde hardcore son de la destrucción de
la ciudad son devastadoras y por ende
como daño colateral los civiles quedan
en la mitad del fuego cruzado y van cómo
interpretar esa posición del kremlin de
defender a los prorrusos defender a los
rusoparlantes para atacar la ciudad con
mayor cantidad de población rusa en
ucrania
es una completa
en el discurso
las acciones que las fuerzas armadas
lusas están tomando el altar ya no por
un lado en 2014 fue muy dramáticos
eventos en los que la intervención en la
invasión en caña en aquel momento fue
justificada en contener la población
lusa
la evidencia que ha surgido desde
entonces y especialmente ahora es que no
hay un particular en particular respecto
acerca de quién quién es el hecho
víctima en este conflicto de la
población civil no hay distinción en ese
sentido en que ucrania no entre alguien
que habla ucraniano y alguien que habla
de uso en nuestra guerra hoy la imagen
que emerge es que el parados ya todos
son caminos en ucrania y portal y de tal
manera
lucharla
zaira su opinión 1 son ucranianos otros
son rusoparlantes tal parece que los
rusos parlantes más tenidos en cuenta
son los que estaban en done jets de
lugansk y los ciudadanos ruso parlantes
de hardcore simplemente tuvieron que
resistir a esta hora siguen resistiendo
los ataques de las fuerzas militares
rusas y el asedio a esta ciudad de poco
más de dos millones y medio de
habitantes
sino la situación a jarkko también es
terrible en
una ciudad tan importante es uso
parlante con un millón y medio lo que
sucede en el
action per al sur yo pienso que aquí hay
una combinación de factores es cierto
que la población está luchando bien
fuerte en contra de lo que ven como una
invasión muy injusta pero también vemos
una desorganización y una falta de
estrategia clara o tal vez las
estrategias que tenían pensada tomando
en consideración el apoyo de la
población rusoparlante no nos fueron
efectivas y no tenían como decir un plan
b
aquí se ha demostrado y luego se están
discutiendo los los especialistas en
seguridad que hasta cierto punto ha
fallado no han fallado los miradores
rusos en la rapidez que se han llevado a
cabo los ataques y como lo han
planificado así que yo diría que hay una
combinación pero hay que entender que
rusia desde un principio quiere
consolidar esta región del este no de
dónde es y luhansk y estas ciudades que
está atacando son texto más importancia
para tener consolidado al menos esta
parte este del del país no antes de que
empezara la guerra muchos de nosotros
éramos muy escépticos en torno a un
ataque a una invasión masiva de ucrania
pero había un cierto mapa circulando en
las redes sociales que hablaba de que
uno de los planes era más o menos
dividir un ucrania como como habrá
sucedido con otros países del mundo
donde han enfrentado este tipo de
conflicto hablemos de corea del norte
corea del sur por ejemplo así que yo
pienso que un poco ellos pensaban que
estas ciudades a estar en el área de
este tener históricamente una relación
más cercana con rusia
y van a tener un apoyo masivo de la
población al no tenerla tal vez no
tenían bien diseñado una estrategia para
para tomarlas de forma más más realidad
yo pienso que una combinación de
factores al salir hablamos entonces de
una estrategia que no les está
funcionando una resistencia ucraniana
que ha tomado por sorpresa no solamente
a los rusos sino al mundo entero ver a
los ciudadanos ucranianos levantados
defendiendo a su país con lo que tienen
con las armas que reciben o con lo que
han podido fabricar en sus propias casas
para defender la soberanía de su país
pero vemos algunos aciertos por parte de
los rusos lo estamos reportando ya
tomaron la ciudad de gerson en el sur
del país muy cerca de la península de
crimea un territorio que también rusia
se anexó que significativo es haber
tomado gerson es una ciudad capital de
una región es significativo esto la
estrategia tal vez será más rápida y no
han podido avanzar tan rápido como ellos
pensaban que análisis hace usted e iván
también le hago la misma pregunta más
adelante
su estancia es importante y gran si
quieres adelante adelante y vano
pero con la captura de nelson ávila
se puede de entrada para las fuerzas
armadas lusas especialmente desde crimea
para avanzar hacia el oeste no obstante
la captura de cada ciudad de cada
sitio
no necesita no garantizar el control
territorial para las fuerzas rusas wk la
ciudad había varios pueblos varias
comunidades que tenían que visitar una
por una y integrada al comando de
ocupación y mientras cada una de estas
comunidades va a existir en alguna
medida u otra
hay un pidiendo una consolidación de la
ocupación de usar de manera tan eficaz
como como ha aparecido en ciertos
lugares y por lo tanto la caída de
hudson no garantiza que el ejército no
sea capaz de penetrar más allá hacia el
oeste desde el punto de primera empieza
a ir en ese orden de ideas tomando en
cuenta lo que dice iván entonces qué
pasa con el cerco a kiev muchas personas
esperaban o por lo menos los rusos
esperaban que cayera en menos de una
semana vemos que se ha ralentizado
la llegada de tropas allí hay problemas
con el suministro no ha sido fácil para
las tropas rusas llegar a kiev y la toma
de la capital que sería digamos una de
las joyas de la corona' en esta batalla
no ha sido tan rápido como la gente
esperaba que puede estar fallando ahí o
parte de la estrategia ganando un poco
de tiempo en el kremlin
yo creo que ahora mismo tal vez el
kremlin está tratando de ganar un poco
de tiempo no las negociaciones no han
vuelto a tener la segunda ronda de
negociaciones como esperábamos para el
día de hoy si están habiendo a medida
que ahora estamos hablando ha habido
unas actuaciones muy importantes muy
fuertes en el centro de kiev en una
estación de ferrocarril de trenes no y
así que un bombardeo constante a mí me
da la impresión de que quieren llevar a
cabo mayor destrucción y asfixiar a la
población y a la misma vez dar un poco
de tiempo tal vez para ver qué se va a
negociar entrar aquí es va a ser un
escenario terrible no es una ciudad
inmensa hay una población que está muy
comprometida con la defensa de su ciudad
el líder ucraniano serhiy ski ha
demostrado ser un líder con gran
capacidad ha unido es el pueblo y
esa batalla una batalla que yo creo que
ninguno de nosotros quisiera ver va a
llevar va a ocasionar mucha muerte de
civiles y también va a ser una masacre
russo que como muy bien visto no es la
prensa rusa pero acabé las redes
sociales en rusia es ruso que estos son
soldados muchos de ellos no preparados
y que tal vez la toma de la ciudad va a
ser un desastre para usted así que yo
diría que está esperando tiempo y ver
que podría resolver las segundas
negociaciones que si no sé que deberían
ser entonces para mañana ya que no se
llevaron a cabo hoy te vamos a hablar de
ese escenario de las negociaciones que
tiene un peso histórico para los rusos
es donde prácticamente comenzó el pueblo
ruso el pueblo eslavo en la antigua luz
de kiev hace muchísimos siglos atrás y
ahí esa conexión histórica que comenzó
entre los rusos y los ucranianos es un
sitio histórico para el pueblo eslavo y
tendría un peso muy grande a nivel
cultural e histórico una caída y una
destrucción de esta ciudad hablemos de
las negociaciones vemos aquí un actor
que también vale la pena analizar iván y
es belarús un país que también te ha
entrado a combatir en cierta forma él
prestó su territorio para el
desplazamiento de las tropas rusas y ya
ha recibido sanciones internacionales en
esta mesa de negociación a tres bandas
que tanto puede avanzar qué análisis
hace usted de esta negociación que no ha
dado ningún tipo de resulta y hasta
ahora
por el momento el helecho que vio las
dos las partes de este conflicto están
hablando de alguna esperanza que la
diplomacia no está más allá de lo
posible en el momento actual en la gente
que las partes han enviado a estas
negociaciones nuestra idea no están
comprometidos a discutir y encontrar una
solución pacífica
y al terminar la idea de actual del lado
de uso no no parece todavía que hay un
no han sido enviados largos o personajes
más importantes de la información hacia
usted no obstante el hecho que hay una
segunda una segunda vuelta de
negociaciones y en todavía que ha habido
concentraciones con las capitales
respectivas esto da alguna esperanza que
él
estas discusiones estas negociaciones no
van
ofrecen una quizás para ofrecer una
salida pero es muy pronto para saber con
certeza y zaira su opinión sobre estas
negociaciones
si es importante de esa línea de
comunicación hay ciertos cánones estos
hablan de que a pesar de que la ciudad
de kharkiv harkov y kiev están asediadas
todavía hay ciertos canales humanitarios
no así que es importante la conversación
que haya una línea de comunicación entre
el jefe craneano y la diplomacia rusa
independientemente de lo que se logre no
a veces están
uno piensa que ambos lados están
pidiendo lo imposible por un lado o
ucrania quiere su crimea de vuelta y no
va a estar de acuerdo con una
independencia para la república de túnez
luhansk claro por otro lado ya sabemos
que hablar es útil cree que ucrania no
es posible con shilinsky así que habría
que ver qué es lo que ambos mandos
quieren quieren negociar yo creo que
estamos en un momento dado donde al
menos lo importante es que hay una una
línea de comunicación abierta entre
ambos grupos y eso nos da a entender de
que van a ver y se van a complementar en
algo positivo
hablemos ahora ya estamos llegando a la
recta final del programa quiero que
hablemos de el discurso desde el kremlin
lo mencionaba al principio del programa
esas declaraciones del canciller ruso
sérguei lávrov hablando de una posible
tercera guerra mundial de escala nuclear
diciéndole al presidente de eeuu que era
la única respuesta que podrían dar ellos
a las sanciones que han recibido luego
tuvo que salir la portavoz de la
cancillería a bajar un poco los nervios
a nivel internacional
y bueno usted creo que ahí se está
contradiciendo un poco el discurso del
kremlin que ya se empiezan a abrir
algunas grietas sobre la información que
se entrega sobre la perspectiva de lo
que pueden pensar putin y blackrock
y el resto de funcionarios que están en
un segundo nivel por debajo de ellos en
cuanto a las declaraciones que hay
discrepancias al interior del kremlin
como lo ve
pienso que por el momento podemos hablar
de problemas de comunicación o de cierto
retardo de la información cuánto tiempo
toma de llegar a un departamento a otro
del kremlin a los ministerios hay que
cobrar de putina de estado por los otros
dos años casi completamente en
adiestramiento
[Música]
lo que levanta muchas preguntas acerca
de la eficiencia
del kremlin para comunicarse con los
ministerios entonces es posible que hay
cierto que tienen la comunicación no
sólo eso pero también
la evidencia que hace que emerge y los
ajustes tácticos y operacionales de la
llega en ucrania de las fuerzas armadas
rusas muestran que están en proceso
también de reconsiderar su estrategia y
esto seguramente causa
ciertas disfunciones en la estrategia de
comunicación por el momento no lo
interpretaría como una
verdadera divergencia en las
perspectivas esto puede haber una
divergencia más adelante sobre todo se
logra continuar sin producir los
resultados esperados pero por el momento
es temprano para que una
disfunción tal de manejo y salida su
opinión sobre este tema si hay leves
grietas dentro del kremlin en cuanto a
las opiniones y qué tan conectado está
el kremlin con el sentir de los rusos de
a pie le pregunto porque veíamos
manifestaciones de ciudadanos rusos en
contra de la guerra miles de ellos
arrestados por la policía rusa y hay un
cierto malestar
entre los ciudadanos por esta invasión
por esta guerra desatada por el ejército
ruso pero también hay que decir que los
ciudadanos están solamente expuestos
el discurso del kremlin a través de los
medios de comunicación los cuales la
gran mayoría de ellos por lo menos la
televisión que es el medio número uno
para informarse allí está controlado por
el estado hay una uniformidad en el
discurso en todos los noticieros y en
los programas
dos cosas yo pienso que en relación al
comentario sobre una posible guerra
nuclear es es un acto de desesperación
no de parte de putin y eso nos da a
entender hasta cierto punto que es
cierto lo que comentan de que está muy
molesto en términos de cómo se ha
llevado a cabo toda la toda la invasión
a ucrania yo lo veo así como una guerra
de discursos pero es muy peligroso lo
que hace tengo una relación a las
protestas si han habido muchísimos
muchísimas protestas y a través de las
redes sociales que aunque algunas están
prohibidas hay que entender que hace
mucho tiempo el ciudadano ruso promedio
ya no ve la televisión no hay acceso
toda esa información a cada vez de las
redes sociales como telegram por decir
un ejemplo pero muchas otras y es muy
creativo no para buscar la información
que necesita así que en ese sentido yo
considero que gran parte de la población
rusa está
completamente abochornado donde está
sucediendo no se lo veía venir esta
invasión no todo el tiempo era como que
era más bien todos unos discursos
bélicos que provenían de washington dice
que eran infundados no me parece que
está tomado de sorpresa arias en parte
de la población rusa se han manifestado
y ellos sí están buscando su información
ya los ya lo han hecho hace muchos años
la represión de putin no es una cosa de
hoy ha venido en crescendo como
decidimos pero ya ya hace 15 años
uno puede decir que los medios
noticiosos están muy controlados pero
y él ha perdido contacto con la
población rusa ahí en historia verdad
esta idea de que los dictadores luego de
que llevan mucho tiempo en el poder
se enajena de la realidad de su
ciudadano promedio y el pueblo ruso no
es el pueblo ruso del 50 de stalin no
este no sea cuelo soviético esta es una
sociedad muy diferente que se ha
aprovechado de pequeños adelantos
democráticos se ha aprovechado la
viabilización viaja y yo creo que él no
está en contacto con esa población no sé
de qué manera van a poder enfrentar las
consecuencias pero creo que es muy
peligroso la decisión que putin ha
tomado salida rápidamente le pregunto le
parece usted que el presidente putin
está en un punto de no retorno que le
cobraría más peso a nivel internacional
a su credibilidad y a su ya su estatus
internacional
a reversar lo que ha hecho retirar
tropas o desescalar esta incursión
militar esta invasión al territorio
ucraniano que continuar con ella y ya
porque efe la caída de ucrania
definitivamente puede ser la mejor
salida que tiene el presidente putin
como lo ve
en mi opinión
y habiendo estudiado a putin yo creo que
es una vez no hay retorno él no va a
retirarse de ucrania va a seguir
atacando desgraciadamente la única forma
de terminar este conflicto es que haya
un cambio de poder pero también va a
depender el apoyo que la otan los
estados unidos le sigue dando que eran
unos términos financieros los millones y
millones y millones que le están
prometiendo ucrania en armamento militar
tienen que llegar ya el apoyo de
inteligencia también a ver hasta qué
punto ucrania puedes seguir enfrentando
a rusia pero el del lado dedujeran del
lado de putin según su carácter no hay
vuelta atrás
iván para terminar el programa quería
preguntarle a usted en particular sé que
usted está en el sureste de estonia es
una ex república soviética un país que
ha estado encendiendo todas las alarmas
desde el inicio de esta confrontación
entre rusia la unión europea eeuu y por
supuesto a ucrania ya han recibido
tropas del ejército inglés el reino
unido ha llevado algunas tropas allí
tienen frontera con rusia y hay un gran
temor
2 los antecedentes históricos que ha
tenido historia ha tenido estonia con
rusia cómo está la percepción de la
gente allí que sienten al ver que eran
invadida por los rusos que dicen los
estonios que dicen que comentan sobre
los rusos sobre los deseos de putin y la
percepción que hay en la calle en el día
a día allí en entorno
hay una gran indignación hacia los
eventos que suceden en ucrania y hay un
gran sentimiento de solidaridad hacia
asia los ucranianos y las víctimas de
esta idea también hay un gran
sentimiento de solidaridad a ser el
pueblo de la luz que se encuentra
participe contra su voluntad en este
conflicto
por otro lado también hay siete
seguridad o ciertos un cierto
sentimiento que la otan
está dispuesta a luchar por la seguridad
de estonia en el país de los países
bálticos
no obstante el hecho que la situación es
tal que hay que acudir a la otan y
contar con lo que él ha agregado que la
diplomacia no es una opción
demuestra que la situación cuando se ha
detallado la situación
si no hay pánico no hay una sensación
que
hay que prepararse para una contingencia
esto no es un país con una muy arraigada
cultura de preparación de tener recursos
en casa de estar listos para cualquier
emergencia pues saben que en efecto en
una historia con los vecinos alrededor
social se siente entonces claro al tema
pues con este testimonio de iván y con
el análisis también de iván y de zaira
cerramos este programa del debate no
cierro con la pregunta habitual de qué
va a suceder porque esta guerra está en
curso y mañana los hechos pueden cambiar
completamente el destino de este país
del este de europa les agradezco a mis
invitados por haber estado con nosotros
hoy haber hecho este análisis y ustedes
gracias por la sintonía sigan con
france24 los espero mañana en el debate
france24 un poco mejor de la garganta
nos vemos
[Música]